but I went to Disney World when I was in
high school and we took acid we took
some LSD now this was a time when people
were experimenting with drugs which is
all the time in America you know if
you've ever been around or opened your
eyes in America
you'll see people on drugs and we went
there we took a bus from Louisiana over
to Orlando Florida here where I am right
now
and we stayed in some [ __ ] motel and it
was a school organized trip and they
brought us down
and and I remember on the bus I'd been
seeing a gal at the time in high school
and I remember we're making love on the
bus I remember that you know be getting
in the middle of the night I remember
you know her you know just escalating
her body on top of me and making love
and mate really making that joy adding
more joy to that bus ride than usual bus
rides because I've been on some other
bus rides and I'm happy to talk about
those and I would like to just while I'm
thinking about it let's make that the
topic for next week if you have been on
a wild bus ride I'm talking Greyhound or
a bus adventure of some sort Peter Pan
you know one of those troubled bus lines
and if you've had a wild experience you
can hit the hotline and let me know
about that and we'll try to drop some of
those in for next week that number is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three now back to your regularly
scheduled programming so we got down to
Orlando and somebody had some acid and
so we took some acid you know a little
bit LSD and I remember if something was
in this LSD it made everybody look Asian
you know if I don't know if we'd you
know if the guy had gotten it had copped
it off of a you know an Asian guy or
Viet or you know a Cambo Cambodian to
call them cam Bose a lot of people but
but we had that Vietnamese acid or
whatever it was a Kambo acid and I
remember everybody I looked at looked
Asian you know and I got 10 eyes so game
recognize game
but when I'm on that acid and
everybody's it just made everybody to
look Asian so where we came there and it
was like graduation night and all of my
high school buddies probably about eight
or nine people on acid and didn't tell
the rest of the class and we're just
running around it's a small world we
probably went on that about nine times
some kid kept drinking the water out of
Pirates of the Caribbean and he got sick
he drank probably about two gallons of
it and he got pretty sick but we just
spent the whole night on acid running
around and doing the different rides and
being scared of each other and being
scared of ourselves and hiding in the
bathroom and like six of us tried to
split a hamburger that's how geeked out
we were and couldn't even do it couldn't
even eat it
but that was a good time and that was
part of high school you know but that
was the last time I'd been to Disney
World and that was only one of two
senior trips now we takin another senior
trip to Mexico Mexico you know one of
the larger countries south of America
and we got down there and everybody I
remember bought a bunch of prescription
pills and was doing was stealing each
other stuff I mean it wasn't but a
couple of probably nine hours we were
down there in Cancun and half the class
and this was a senior trip in high
school half the class was you know
hopped up on prescription pills and
stealing each other's luggage and
selling each other's [ __ ] on the streets
and you know getting stealing each
other's whatever it was at the time we
didn't have cell phones we have those
calculators ti-85 s as fancy you know
you laters and we were you know those
number crunchers and you know that do
though they do algebra and we were
stealing those and selling them and
buying more pills and I mean for a group
of seventeen or eighteen 19 year olds it
only took us about about 12 hours to go
completely AWOL and half of us be
addicted to painkillers and out there
selling each other's goods and uh and
different type of textiles and wares so
that got that got bad then everybody's
fighting him is and not half of a
were sharing a room and I'm a were
stealing stuff from each other and
hiding it in the same room we were in so
that right there will tell you what some
prescription pills will do to you you
know so that's one thing you just stay
off of but anyhow that was um and a lot
more happen on that trip but that was
some of those high school trips in one
of those was to Disney Disney town good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watch this one